- [Narrator] During the
boom of climate investing,
there's a surprising
industry that's expected
to rake in the green.
It's garbage.
North America's biggest landfill operator,
which manages your waste, is known as...
- WM.
- [Narrator] It's best
known for collecting trash
and putting it in a landfill.
- If you've lived in America
and you've thrown something away,
chances are they have handled your trash.
- [Narrator] But beginning in 2026,
the company says
sustainability focused ventures
will reach 15% of its total profit
or about $740 million a year.
Here's how the company plans to profit
from government tax credits and a market
that's hungry for renewable
energy and recycled materials.
This is the economics of WM.
Over the next four years, WM
plans to invest $1.2 billion
into making fuel from rotting garbage.
When the trash that ends up
in a landfill decomposes,
it releases a slew of gases.
One of them is methane, known
commercially as natural gas,
which is more environmentally harmful
to the atmosphere than carbon dioxide.
Landfill owners would
previously capture methane
and burn it off to prevent it
from seeping into the atmosphere.
Now, they collect the gases
and nearby plants separate the methane,
which is piped into power
plants for electricity
or into homes for heating and cooking.
WM already operates 66 landfill gas plants
all over the country.
Landfill gas is much more expensive
to produce than gas drilled
by energy companies.
But thanks to federal tax breaks
and other incentives to reduce pollution,
landfill gas has become
economically viable
for producers and buyers.
WM expects to receive $250
million in tax credits
installing gasworks at
18 of its landfills.
Thanks to last year's climate,
tax, and healthcare bill.
- The climate bill really was a bit
more of a catalyst to do it faster.
- Waste Management is
pursuing these projects,
because they're immensely
profitable right now,
and it's made projects
that's smaller landfills,
which will be less productive
than large landfills.
It's brought them into the
money, they're now economical.
- [Narrator] WM says this expansion
will allow it to produce
eight times more gas
than it does now, and
will generate $500 million
in additional profit through 2026,
not counting the tax breaks.
Currently, natural gas from
landfills only accounts
for less than 1% of the
US natural gas supply.
But because of the growing demand,
the number of renewable
natural gas projects,
including landfills,
has nearly doubled in the past five years,
and production has
significantly increased.
WM's competitors are also cashing in
with their own landfill gas plants.
Republic Services is planning
to open a total of 77
renewable energy projects,
and reported that about
88% of its landfills
are covered in biogas collection systems.
But WM is not just investing in landfills.
The Waste Management company
is making large investments
in upgrading its recycling plants,
like this one outside of Cleveland.
- Our 100,000 square foot
facility is built to manage
12,000 tons a month of recycling.
- [Narrator] These
investments are helping plants
to increase recycling recovery rates,
and the company expects the
new tech to add $240 million
to its bottom line over
the next four years.
- The WM Cleveland facility prior
was a commercial recycling plant,
so we could not offer single
stream commercial recycling.
This investment now has
opened up our capacity
to both residential and
commercial recycling.
We're able to provide single
stream recycling for them.
- [Narrator] One of WM's upgrades
involves automating its recycling plants
with optical sorters powered by AI.
- So behind me is one
of 12 optical scanners
within our process system.
The optical scanners are made to pick
900 to 1,000 picks per minute.
Through programming and imaging,
it identifies a specific product
and there's an air jet that
then identifies that product
onto a conveyor over to
the baler to be bailed
for the end user.
- It makes the sorting go a lot faster.
It removes human air,
and what they found is
that it really boosts
not only the quantity
of the what they call recovered materials,
but they're getting a better quality.
It's cleaner, it's not a
jumble of other stuff in there.
So they're spending a
lot of money to automate
these recycling facilities
in order to boost efficiency.
- Where we have made these investments
we're lowering our
operating costs by reducing
some of the labor
intensity of the business.
- All that stuff goes to these facilities
where it's sorted into
different materials,
you know, mixed paper, corrugated
cardboard, clear bottles,
that all gets separated.
That's a very intense labor,
not a very pleasant job.
These companies have a really hard time
keeping people in those jobs.
- [Narrator] And these optical
sorters have already begun
to increase revenue.
Recyclables have become an increasingly
valuable commodity themselves
as more companies promise
to use recycled packaging.
- There's a big shortage of the materials
of recycled material that companies
like Coca-Cola, or Amazon,
or whoever uses a lot of plastic and paper
can reuse for new packaging.
So the race is on to really get that stuff
out of the waste stream, and
companies are willing to pay up
for those materials even
though they're more expensive,
because they've told their
investors and their customers
they're gonna clean up their act.
- [Narrator] Plus, more
cleanly sorted recyclables
fetch a higher price.
WM says the optical sorters
are able to increase
blended commodity value
by about 15% per ton,
and the company expects that it'll be able
to recover 25% more
reusable materials by 2025.
- We're continuously
looking at that algorithm
to make sure that we capture
more material long term.
- [Narrator] And
sustainability investments
are even going back to one
of WM's core businesses.
Collections.
- People need to do the
job right at the start,
and we have a technology that we use
called smart truck that
helps us with that.
- [Narrator] Smart trucks
come equipped with cameras.
When the truck tips
recyclables into its hopper,
it's tech captures
footage of the materials
for a team of technicians to review.
These technicians scan for any objects
that can't be recycled
and monitor the amount of recyclables.
If WM detects misplaced
recyclables or overflowing bins,
it sends a notification to its commercial
and residential customers
informing them of the issue.
- In our regions where we have
that smart truck technology,
we've seen residue reduce
roughly 20% in those markets,
so that's key.
Let's just say a really dirty
pizza box mixed in with paper.
You know, that good
paper or good cardboard
gets contaminated and
then it can't be recycled.
- [Narrator] Much of this technology
is already in place today.
- We definitely think about the materials
that are in our landfills as just that,
materials, they're a resource.
- What we think of as trash,
a lot of it is really some
of the hottest commodities
of the green economy.
(gentle music)